[Music]
you
[Music]
whether you're brand new to the series
or just a little rusty Mario Kart 8
deluxe can be sort of intimidating it's
a cute racing game but it has the
potential to make you rage harder than
you ever knew you could so if you want
to destroy your enemies and all of your
friends here's what you tips the game
doesn't really tell you make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss any more
Mario Kart first things first you
probably know how to accelerate and
steer but if you really want to start
racing you gotta know how to boost to
get a boost at the start of a race press
and hold a as the countdown fades from 2
you do it too late you'll get a tinier
boost but if you're too early you'll
totally stall during the race press R
when you're going off a jump or ramp to
get a boost but if you're going too fast
into a turn don't be afraid to break so
you don't go flying off the track you
can also press X to check what's behind
you it's useful for seeing who or what
is coming your way note that two new
settings Auto steer and Auto accelerate
are on by default so if you're not into
that be sure to turn them off before you
start once you've gotten the hang of
driving it's time to drift this one
takes some practice your main goal is to
turn as tightly and quickly as possible
to keep your time low and prevent
yourself from flying off the track and
the longer you drift the better your
speed boost will be when you let go
you'll see sparks flying off your cart
when and where you should begin drifting
depends on your car configuration which
we'll get to in a bit but as a general
rule of thumb for carts at least start
drifting right before the curved part of
the track starts bikes have much better
handling than carts and require a
lighter touch so if you're new to
drifting I recommend starting out on
carts first to get a feel for it
once you've played a bit you'll probably
have a fair amount of coins you can
collect up to ten each race don't ignore
them because they go toward unlocking
cart parts and car customization really
matters carts have five stats speed
acceleration weight handling and
traction press the plus or minus button
to see stats in the cart selection
screen the first two are pretty
self-explanatory the speed stat
indicates your top speed while
acceleration is how quickly you gain
speed and therefore recover from getting
hit or falling off the track weight is
what it sounds like in carts with a
higher weight can knock away those with
lower weights handling dictates how
sharp a turn you can make and is really
important for tougher tracks and higher
difficulties and note that bikes have
higher handling than carts and make much
sharper turns finally traction is how
well your car can grip the road and it
can help keep you from slowing down too
much on off-road terrain experiment with
different kart fields to find one that
works for you I prefer high top speed
middle acceleration and high handling
over anything else these stats are
partially affected by the character you
choose there are three main weight
classes light medium and heavy with a
bit of variation within them characters
like the baby's toad and dry bones are
light mid-sized characters like Mario
Peach Yoshi in the Inklings are medium
and larger and metal characters like
Rosalina Bowser Wario and pink gold
peach are heavy heavier characters have
higher top speeds but lower acceleration
handling and traction so tailor your
Kart to account for the character you
choose Nintendo's record best times on
the wii u version we're set with heavy
characters using the sport bike slick
wheels and parafoil glider for the most
part for right now I'm rocking the mid
weight inkling girl with the splat buggy
slick wheels and super glider and it's
working well for my style
I recommend testing out new kart configs
in the time trials mode to see which
setups get you the best times
once you've mastered the art of racing
it's time to unleash hell upon your
opponents
that's where items come in
you can use items with L but if you hold
L you can carry some items like bananas
and shells behind you if you're targeted
by a red or green shell they'll protect
you from getting hit just don't do it
with a BA bomb because it'll explode
if you're in first and you get a super
horn hold on to it it can knock away
items and other racers but it can also
protect you from the infamous blue shell
use it while the shell is hovering over
you to destroy it and everyone else's
hopes of winning even if you've unlocked
everything you could possibly want don't
ignore coins having 10 grants you a very
small top speed boost and it can mean
the difference between first and second
place finally when you get a mushroom
save it for shortcuts it'll help you
make it over grass or other weird
surfaces you can save a bunch of time if
you're curious about where the best
shortcuts are you're in luck because we
already have a handy video all about
them now that you're a master class
racer let us know in the comments what
other tips and tricks you stumble upon
thanks for watching
[Music]